lisa jack lemmon bonjour bienvenue à la
maison je vous emmène aujourd'hui je
vous invite à la maison pour prendre
l'apéro autour de la table basse pour
garder ce nouveau téléviseur téléviseurs
de sony c'est la nouvelle a8 de 2020
télé qui est intéressant très
intéressante et sur plein de points
d'eau xive de temps de recharge d'un
téléviseur et bien vous allez tout
savoir sur son modèle 55 pouces que j'ai
ici qui existent également 65
mais ici on va se parler du 55 parce que
c'est déjà très très grand chez moi
regarder le 55 pouces et jusqu'à 65
ça va déborder tous les côtés mais
peut-être que 65 pouces sera fait pour
aller chez vous a donc tous regardé tous
dire au niveau de l'écran du son de la
télécommande du tout la partie software
la partie logicielle bien évidemment il
ya plein de choses à raconter c'est
vachement intéressant il ya très beau
boulot qui a été fait par sony sur ce
téléviseur n'est pas parfait mais il est
vraiment pas loin de l'être
et il est très sympa donc on va se
regarder ça d'ici quelques instants mais
juste avant le saisit pas déjà le cas
je vous invite à venir vous abonnez vous
cliquez sur le petit bouton rouge qui
s'affiche qu'il est en tout le temps là
en permanence si les rouches et vous
n'êtes pas abonné dont vous cliquez
dessus vous vous abonnez vous actionnez
la petite cloche pour être notifié dès
qu'une nouvelle vidéo sortira et ça
croyez moi c'est vachement bien parce
qu'on a plein de choses à se raconter et
je vous aide aussi bien choisir votre
téléviseur vous voyez comme celui là ici
on parle bien évidemment de smartphones
de votre vie numérique comme vous le
voyez derrière comment protéger son
smart phone control vol 10 erreurs qui
mettre en danger votre smartphone 8
preuve que vous êtes accro à vos
smartphones et je vous parle bien
évidemment de plein d'autres choses dont
cliquer sur le petit bouton souhait
comme ça vous saurez tout téléviseur à
8,2 2020 je vous le disais la première
chose qu'on va venir voir ici lorsque
vous la regardez dit moi ça vous frappe
aux yeux en bas en commentaire c'est
déjà le design leed et cafés du sony là
dessus s'est vraiment joué sur un design
épuré débord extrêmement fin du côté un
peu minimaliste pour que votre
expérience de visionnage ne soit pas
bloquée ne soit pas embêtés par
quelconque détails
vous avez des bords qui sont vraiment
extrêmement fin d'un côté comme de
l'autre de autant bas ça ajoute vraiment
à la sensation d'immersion l'autre point
c'est que vous avez un cadre qui est
vraiment extrêmement fins le design
s'appelle wang slate vous avez deux
positions en première position qui est
un peu standard qui permet de me reposer
votre télé à fleurs enfin quasiment à
fleurs a pas grand chose vous le voyez
comme ça et venir les surélever ensuite
de 7 cm c'est très sain qu'en fait tu
voulais tourner à 90 degrés ça vous sur
elle et votre télé ça vous permet de
dire qu'elle est une barre de saut en
dessous est aussi un point qui est très
malin je sais pas si vous vous en
rendrez compte c'est que il est
absolument aucun câble qui dépasse de
derrière
regardez c'est très très très propre
parce que vous avez un passage de cap
qui est vraiment intelligente je suppose
que vous en douterez on a des câbles
daria mais l'idée en fait c'est que les
câbles ils passent dans le pied vous
avez une petite barrette en plastique
que vous venez descendre vous glissez
vos câbles à l'intérieur et deviennent
complètement invisible lorsque vous
regardez votre téléviseur pour un design
chic maintenant vous avez un deuxième
point c'est surtout de plus importante
un des plus importants pour moi là
dessus c'est vraiment votre talent vous
avez si une dalle 4 ko l'aide 3840 par
2160 ici je vous ai dit c'est un 55
pouces c'est un écran 100 hertz hdmi
compatible dolby vision un des premiers
points à prendre en considération est ce
qu'on va regarder cette télé c'est
effectivement leur angle de visionnage
je peux mettre sur le côté et quelques
soins monde en passant parce que voyez
moi j'ai mon canapé qui est là mais
quelles que soient mes déplacements
eh bien je vais avoir un bon angle de
visionnage alors vous le voyez ici ça
c'est mon éclairage qui est l'admets
chez vous je suis sûr vous n'aurez pas
ça
mais quel que soit votre position les
angles de vision sont très très très
très beau le seul truc en peut-être
venir un petit peu regretter ici c'est
qu'on va pas avoir le meilleur
traitement anti reflet d'une baie vitrée
qui est juste là on la devine le mieux
vous mettez dans votre pièce vous mettez
pas de baie vitrée derrière et là vous
êtes vraiment profiter d'une expérience
complètement maximiser je vais pas vous
faire l'énumération toutes les technos
vous avez derrière mais s'il faut savoir
vous avez déjà le processeur x1 ultimate
de sonner c'est un processeur sans qu'on
s'en maison qu'il a portée de la
performance nous permettra d'avoir plein
de techno derrière pour venir optimiser
votre image le premier point qui est
extrêmement importante
si vous n'allez pas voir une
optimisation globale de l'image vous
allez voir une optimisation détail par
détail élément par élément ce qui
permettra par exemple c'est pourquoi
dans une image avec une voiture d'un
côté avec lorient - bordeaux un chien ou
ce que vous voulez et bien chaque
élément va être optimisée indépendamment
ce soit du point de vue de la luminosité
ce n'est pas une vue de la couleur du
contraste pour que le rendu de chaque
élément soit le plus juste possible le
plus qualitatif pour vous ayez vous
visuellement le meilleur rendu mais ça
ne jure pas vous allez pas avoir un
élément qui va être plus pêchus plus
lumineux ou plus contrastée qu en oeuvre
d'un ensemble qui est extrêmement
cohérent parce qu'ici vous avez des
analyses de l'image qui fait en temps
réel on retrouve la technologie pixel
contraste booster qui va venir à
optimiser la luminosité la couleur le
contraste mais également les autres mais
ça ne s'arrête pas là puisque on
retrouve également la technologie x
motion clarity qui va éviter les flous
et qui va apporter plus de netteté dans
tous vos films et notamment si vous
allez par exemple regarder un film
d'action mais ça ne s'arrête pas là et
vous vous en douterez parce que
les contenus que vous allez avoir sur
votre téléviseur sont pas forcément des
contenu 4k vous allez peut-être la voir
sur certains matchs de foot ou quelques
programmes mais la plupart du temps vous
allez avoir du full hd ce que va faire
votre téléviseur ici il n'a pas voulu
diffuser une image en full hd il va
prendre votre image full hd il va faire
ce qu'on appelle de l'umps keirin il va
venir monter la qualité du full hd pour
obtenir un résultat sensiblement proche
de la 4 car en tout cas une lutte vous
aurez un résultat qui sera extrêmement
qualitatif pour pouvoir profiter de
votre contenu full hd en qualité 4k
c'est un peu ça l'idée
- des trucs qui va le plus bluffé c'est
qu'ici en fait vous n'avez absolument
aucun haut parleurs pour le médium et
pour légumes vous pouvez regarder
allez-vous vous les voyez on est
vraiment à fleurs normalement les haut
parleurs se situe juste en dessous au
niveau des téléviseurs là vous n'en avez
pas alors on peut regarder ici
effectivement on va dire qu'on n'a pas
des haut parleurs et la techno qui en
fait extrêmement intéressant c'est que
vous avez deux moteurs sous l'écran qui
viennent faire vibrer bogdan vous avez
une vibration de l'écran qui vont venir
créer l'audio et c'est assez plus fort
vous vous en rendrez pas contre vous
mais moi là je pose ma main je sens
l'écran qui vibre quelles que soient les
endroits alors j'ai plus qu'à passer un
petit coup de chiffres d'après toi pour
venir nettoyer mais le truc absolument
incroyable vous avez cet écran qui va
venir vibrer qui va créer une onde
sonore pour les médiums et pour les
aigus mais pour les bas c'est pas
possible parce qu'il faudrait vibrations
beaucoup plus ample dont du coup j'avais
retrouvé quand même 2 petit caisson de
basses qui sont planqués à l'arrière de
votre téléviseur que vous ne verrez pas
comme ça et qui vont venir créer
effectivement elles sont très graves et
la qualité audio là parce qu'on pourrait
le dire j'ai ma télé qui vibrait ce que
le saut une bonne qualité je puis vous
assurer qu'on s'en rend pas compte
on est impressionné par des
haut-parleurs c'est fou en train de se
dire qu'on n'a pas de haut parleurs
quand une vibration dans le techno et
pas toutes nouvelles chez sony avait
déjà utilisé depuis quelques années mais
c'est vrai que je n'avais pas testé mois
chez moi comme ça et c'est vraiment
bluffant ça fonctionne extrêmement bien
l'idée derrière cette techno ce que
vient faire ce nom c'est vraiment
d'apporter une expérience plus
cinématographique puisque si vous êtes
au cinéma vous avez votre toile et vos
parleurs sont placés impériaux pas leurs
principaux se replacer derrière l'écran
pour vraiment restituer la directivité
du sens quand quelqu'un pas le son sans
vraiment de l'endroit où la personne va
parler pour créer cette sensation
d'immersion et c'est vraiment l'idée ce
qu'on a à me retrouver ici c'est à dire
que la leçon va être vraiment très
central c'est quelqu'un va paraître le
côté ne sont pas plus arrivés du côté on
est vraiment dans cette sensation
d'immersion global après il ya d'autres
techno qui sont développés par sony pour
renforcer un petit peu cette sensation
de spatialisation notamment la techno us
forces fonte
monde font entre en phase qui va vous
créé une sas au plus d'immersion comme
si vous aviez 1,5 point autour de vous
ça n'ira pas aussi loin que si vous avez
tout un système d'enceintes chez vous
mais c'est vrai que la spatialisation
autour du téléviseur quand vous êtes
vraiment positionné en face est très
très bonne on a également une telle vie
compatible dolby atmos on a aussi une
techno qui s'appelle le zoute vocale qui
va venir des tâches et les voies sur les
fréquences bien évidemment médium vous
en douterez et notamment lorsque vous
avez beaucoup de bruit dans une pièce et
c'est justement là que ça devient
intéressant c'est que votre télé elle va
venir s'adapter par rapport à votre
environnement si vous êtes dans un
environnement vous avez très très peu de
lumière et bien la luminosité de votre
écran va venir s'adapter silva contrario
vous avez beaucoup lumière avec comment
une baie vitrée qu'on en plein jour en
plein été qu'il fait très chaud et très
beau et bien failli repousser la
luminosité qu'on vous ayez toujours
quelque chose qui soit très juste alors
vous vous êtes pas forcément vous en
rendre compte à l'oeil nu que ce que
vous verrez toujours de la même manière
quel que soit la luminosité ambiante et
vous avez un capteur de lumière qui va
venir vraiment réguler la luminosité de
votre écran pour que ce soit
complètement invisible extrêmement
confortable à regarder ici on tourne sur
une android tv
vous avez une petite télécommande à la
télécommande j'ai tout de suite vous en
parler je trouve qu'elle a un design un
petit peu un peu passé on n'est pas
extrêmement premium pouvoir compter sur
une télé premium après côté pratique
c'est qu'on va retrouver les boutons les
plus importants notamment le bouton
netflix ici si on souhaite accéder les
fixes très rapidement on a le googleplex
pour pouvoir venir à louer des films des
séries ce que vous voulez bon froid
pourquoi pas vous allez retrouver vos
boutons pour naviguer un peu
classiquement back home tv le bouton tv
qui moi en tout cas va me servir à
allumer mon décodeur parce que oui cette
télécommande est une télécommande
universelle et ça c'est vachement bien
donc la ja vient de proposer savoir si
je veut allumer mon décodeur ou pas et
vous avez un petit bouton ici qui est
très cool pour me rappeler votre
assistant vocal quelle heure est-il
google il est midi 22 j'écoute personne
n'entend pas ici parce que oui
effectivement vous allez pouvoir avoir
soit amazon alexa soit google assistant
le point qui est très cool c'est que
vous pouvez venir piloter votre télé
depuis votre enceinte
amazon alexa ou alors google comme
google laisse google laisse mini ce que
vous voulez vous pouvez le faire très
facilement prévenir
allumez votre télé pourrait venir
éteindre votre télé à distance parce que
vous êtes couché vous avez oublié de
l'éteindre
oki google est à la télé vous avez en
plus du chrome cas ce dont vous pouvez
venir envoyer du contenu depuis votre
smartphone depuis votre ordinateur
devenir chrome castet extrêmement
facilement et en plus c'est une
technique est compatible apple airplay
et apple nous quitte côté applications
et bien vous avez beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de possibilités à vous
avez votre télé qui veut dire d'allumer
mon décodeur ça je vous le dis netflix
traque vidéos youtube les services de
google google plaide films et séries
disney plus des services supplémentaires
sony pourrait venir ensuite ajouté vous
directement tout ce que vous vous les
voyez pas se remettre un petit jeune qui
tu as fait neuf pour venir à m'amuser
directement facebook watch france tv
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
possibilités mick hannah les compagnies
donc ça c'est vraiment cool
j'ai en tout plus de 5000 applications
que je peux venir installer directement
je vais avoir ensuite ma sélection une
sélection de vidéos km fait sur les
différentes plateformes que soit netflix
my canal molotov rakuten rmc sport et
compagnie ont bador du spotify également
pour écouter de la musique la télé
netflix avec des suggestions en fonction
de mes goûts en fonction de ce qui
cartonne en ce moment et puis mes
recommandations sur youtube et puis une
sélection d'applications molotov
my canal à vous de choisir ce que vous
voulez vous allez podcast avec tunein
est un très bon et venir modifier soit
le déplacer le mettre en å le mettre en
bas prévient vraiment customiser votre
télé comme vous le souhaitez ou alors
carrément venir supprimer une section si
vous trouvez qu'elle correspond pas à ce
que vous voulez faire
donc vous voyez qu'en terme de qualité
d'affichage en termes de qualité audio
en terme d'expérience on a vraiment un
truc qui est extrêmement complet mais
sony a été encore un peu plus loin parce
que vous le savez sony est une
entreprise il ya 360 degrés ils ont
l'audio et dont les télés ils ont le
gaming ils ont les smartphones ils vont
beaucoup de choses ils sont également
présents au cinéma le cinéma c'est un
point qui est extrêmement important pour
sony et elle s'appuie dessus et quelles
que soient les diverses sur lesquelles
vous êtes notamment si vous regardez au
niveau de l'xperia one encore mark 1 et
marque 2 encore plus loin sur une idée
du cinéma il s'appuie vraiment dessus et
là bien évidemment ils sont allés là
dessus également et notamment avec
netflix puisque vous avez le netflix
calibre ait mode alors je vous passe un
peu le truc
l'idée derrière tout ça c'est de venir
vous proposer un contenu qui est
complètement dans l'esprit de ce qu'a
voulu faire le réalisateur on va venir
garder les lumières on va bien gardé les
couleurs si vous avez un produit qui est
très sombre
une série un peu dark et bien vous allez
vraiment avoir le contenu de votre télé
va venir complètement s'adapter par
rapport à ce qu'a souhaité les
réalisateurs en respectant les réglages
précis du réalisateur c'est à dire que
la télé va venir en vaut avoir des
paramètres complètement customisée
quelle que soit la série et ce en
fonction des choix du réalisateur dont
vous n'allez pas avoir les mêmes
paramètres d'une série
à l'autre mais ça ne s'arrête pas là
parce qu'on a aussi le label perfect for
playstation sony c'est aussi le gagner
et vous le savez la playstation on a eu
une ps4 et la tende alpes et s5 les ps 5
qui arrive est bien évidemment cette
télé est complètement optimisé pour le
gaming avec un faible input lag mais ça
ne s'arrête pas là puisque vous avez un
double tuner vous allez donc pouvoir
regarder un fume série ce que vous
voulez et enregistrer une autre de
l'autre côté sur un disque vous allez
pouvoir brancher en usb
on se fait un tour du côté de la
connectique vous allez avoir une prise
casque
vous avez une sortie audio vous avez de
l'usb vous avez une entrée hdmi et tout
le reste est planqué ici vous avez une
prise ethernet vous avez de l'âge des
amis 2.0 heures vous en avez quatre en
tout dont celle sur laquelle je suis
branché c'est de lit ar c'est d'être
branché cap tnt sortie vidéo composite
sortie casque trois ports usb
enfin je vous en passe et des meilleures
à noter que vous avez également du
bluetooth 4.2 et ya un truc que je
trouve aussi intéressante sur
l'installation elle est très facile vous
avez un énorme carton vous ai pas filmer
l'installation mais j'aurais pu vous
avez un énorme carton vous enlevez le
carton vous enlevez les polystyrènes
sauf celui qui est positionné au milieu
et vous venez insérer vos pieds
directement d'un côté il éclipse et de
l'autre vous n'avez plus qu'à prendre la
télé la soûlerie à la poser
et si vous n'avez pas besoin de venir là
prendre la retourner la pause est vissé
davis il ya un côté très pratique à
l'installation et ça évite les
manipulations qui pourrait être
hasardeuse bon pour le coup c'est plutôt
bien pensé à ses mains donc il fallait
souligner moi ce que j'aime bien sur
scène et viseur c'est l'idée de sony qui
vous emmène encore plus loin dans son
univers sony fait des télé sony est
aussi due l'autre côté de l'écran dans
la production audiovisuelle et ils
maîtrisent très bien la chaîne l'idée
d'emmener les spectateurs encore plus
loin grâce à de l'immersion grâce à un
son qui est produit par la vibration
nadal c'est très très bien cet écran
extrêmement bien maîtrisé à vous pouvez
aller plus loin si vous le souhaitez au
niveau des paramètres pourraient venir
modifier la couleur contre à saturation
vous pourrez faire manuellement si vous
n'aimez pas le côté un peu neutre de
l'image si vous voulez rajouter plus de
saturation et bien vous pouvez le faire
il ya pas mal de paramètres qu'on peut
venir customiser manuellement moi
personnellement comme ils sont là de
réglages de base selon qu'ils sont très
juste très bon et ça me convient pas
besoin d'autre chose
moi personnellement j'aime bien cet
ailier le coûte le prix tarif de de 1199
euros à sa sortie avec plus ou moins de
variations en fonction des périodes que
ce soient les seules compagnies à vous
de me dire vous
maintenant ce que vous en pensez est-ce
que vous avez déjà lu un téléviseur sony
est ce que celui là pourrait vous
intéresser
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à changer
et est ce que vous pourriez changer pour
ce modèle là et d'ailleurs si vous
intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description des matchs ou en
commentaire quant à lyon se trouve
extrêmement rapidement parce qu'à plein
de choses qui arrivent du côté de la tec
ne m'en étais latex ne s'arrête pas aux
mamans beaucoup d'amour prenez soin de
vous et à très vite
ciao ciao
[Musique]